So why do we care about Virtualization?
Well, first it enables consolidation.
And consolidation is this ability to run
multiple virtual machines, with their
operating systems and applications,
on a single physical platform.
Consolidation then leads to
improved cost efficiency.
With pure machines, with less space,
potentially with fewer admins, and
with fewer electrical bills, we will be
able to run the same kind of workload.
So consolidation delivers benefits
because it allows us to decrease costs,
and also to improve
the manageability of the system.
In addition with Virtualization,
once the operating system
in its applications are nicely
encapsulated in a VM, and
decoupled from the actual
physical hardware.
It becomes more easy to migrate
the OS in the applications
from one physical machine to
another physical machine.
Or even to copy and
clone them onto multiple physical
machines at the same time.
As a result, Virtualization leads
to mechanisms that are useful
in order to provide greater
availability of the services.
Like, for instance, if we have
an increase in the load, we can just,
create multiple VMs and
address that issue.
So, increase the availability
of the system.
And also to provide solutions
that improve the reliability.
For instance,
if we detect that a particular hardware
node is getting hot and likely will
fail, we can just migrate those VMs
onto some other physical nodes.
There are other benefits
to Virtualization.
For instance because the OS and
the applications are nicely
encapsulated in a virtual machine.
It becomes more easy to contain any
kinds of bugs, or any kinds of malicious
behavior, to those resources that are
available to the virtual machine only,
and not to potentially affect
the entire hardware system.
Speaking of debugging, in particular,
Virtualization has delivered
some other benefits,
that it has become a very important
platform for operating systems research.
It let's systems researchers quickly
introduce new operating system feature
and has them in the OS that's
encapsulated in the VM.
And then they have ability to more
quickly view the effects of that and
debug it as opposed to
a more traditional cycle,
which would have included hardware
restarts of the machines and
then searches through the log files or
the error files, etc.
Virtualization is also useful because
it provides affordable support for
legacy operating systems.
With Virtualization it's no
longer necessary to designate
some hardware resources for
some older operating system
just because it's needed to run one
particular application, for instance.
Instead, that legacy OS and applications
can be packaged in a virtual machine and
then can be co-allocated,
consolidated, on
the same hardware resources that support
other VMs and other applications.
And there are many other
benefits to Virtualization.
These are some of the key ones, though.